الاتحاد من اجل الديمقراطيه والتقدم
المشارك في الحكومه وثاني اكبر احزاب
الموبايلات تمثيلا في البرلمان لا يخفي
ابتعاضه من تصريح للوزير الاول اعتبر حزب
الانصاف الحاكم شركه الاتحاد في الحكومه
والموالاه واجهه النظام السياسيه الوحيده
والتقدم مستقبل هذه التصريحات او هذه
التهديدات لمستوى عالي من الاستغراب
والاستهجان والاستياء لانها ليست مقبوله
وليست متفهمه من حزب نتقاسم ونحن وهو
اغلبيه دائما لفخامه رئيس الجمهوريه
احزاب المعارضه انتقدت ما وصفتها بالحمله
التي يقودها اعضاء الحكومه لصالح الحزب
الحاكم واعتبر التصريحات المسؤولين
الحكوميين دليلا على سعي النظام للهيمنه
المطلقه على المشهد السياسي ورفضه للشراكه
حتى مع حلفائه فالمعارضه لا يمكن ان
يخالف بعضها بعض وان تشترك في معارك
سياسيه وكذلك الاغلبيه فكان كل منهم منسجم
في اطاره ويكون لهم يبحث عن تقويه الطرف
الاخر اما ان تكون الصراع الداخليه فهذه
اول مره وما يحدث الان بين الاغلبيه
والحزب الحاكم فهو مساله غريبه
يحجم قاده حزب الانصاف عن رفض او تبني
التصريحات التي اثارت استياء احزاب
الموالاه
وتجنبنا ابراهيم رئيس الحزب الرد على سؤال
للعربيه عما اذا كانت التصريحات المثيره
تمثل موقف الحزب الرسمي
ونوابه
واعطى الحزب تنم
والناطقون الرسميون باسمه يوضحون موقف
الحزب
الاخرى
ما يقول الاخرون
انشغالا تاما بما اقوله انا وحد قيادات
الحزب او رئيس الحزب ناطق الرسمي يسعى
الحزب الحاكم خلال هذه الانتخابات الى
الحفاظ على اغلبيه مريحه في البرلمان
بينما تسعى احزاب الاغلبيه الى تعزيز
تمثيلها البرلماني مدعومه بالوزن السياسي
لبعض المغاضبين من حزب الانصاف ترشحوا تحت
الوانها ابراهيم مصطفى العربيه نواكشوط
لمتابعه المزيد الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات